The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
We're still on Exam 2 of
the fall 2009 class.
We're going to be doing
problem number 2 now.
This is the x-ray problem,
as I like to call it.
It's kind of exciting.
Let's talk about what we need
to know before we actually
reasonably try to attempt
this problem.
So I would review these
things again.
We want to know emission line
nomenclature, how to name
emission lines.
We want to know Moseley's Law.
We want to know Bragg's Law,
and I would also emphasize,
I'll get onto it later, you
want to know how to derive
Bragg's Law as well.
We want to know, this is
pronounced Bremsstrahlung,
it's a German word which means
breaking radiation.
So Bremsstrahlung radiation.
And we also want to know some
reflection rules, and I'll
sort of elucidate
that a bit more.
But let me start you off
in that direction.
So getting on to part A, we
are told that somebody has
been horsing around with
our x-ray machine.
We've all had this
problem before.
And they've changed
the target.
So let me first tell you what a
target is, and how the x-ray
machine looks.
Then we'll be able to understand
what exactly it is
we're trying to figure out.
An x-ray machine, basically
the x-ray source involves
electrons being accelerated
into a
target material, a metal.
And then that gives off a whole
bunch of electromagnetic
radiation, so photons.
Some of those photons we'll talk
a little about later, in
the Bremsstrahlung spectrum,
are very
characteristic of the material.
So I'm going to call, you know,
we have long wavelength
photons, short wavelength
photons.
Some of the photons have a very
characteristic wavelength
or frequency that corresponds
to a particular electron
transition.
We're going to talk more about
this in a little bit, but I'm
going to call this the
K-alpha photon, OK?
So that just happens to
be in metals, x-ray.
We know that for particular
materials, we have particular
K-alpha wavelengths.
And what's basically happened
in this problem is that, you
know, maybe we knew what this
material was before, and then
all of a sudden we weren't
around, somebody switched it
on us, and now we have to
figure out what it is.
Don't you hate when
that happens?
So the best way to approach this
problem is to understand
Moseley's Law, and then have
it on your equation sheet.
We allow all of our students to
have an equation sheet, and
also a periodic table.
So don't panic if you can't
memorize this equation.
Our students are expected to,
not to memorize it, but to
understand it.
So this is Moseley's Law.
And Moseley's Law basically
tells us, let me go through
these variables.
We have the wave number.
We have a Rydberg constant.
This is a bunch of physical
constants, sort of
agglomerated into one big one,
to save us some time.
We have the final energy level,
where the electron
ends, and we have the initial
energy level where it begins.
And then we have z, which
designates our element.
So it's the number of protons
we have in the
nucleus, for example.
And then we have this sigma.
OK?
So, you know, in order to solve
this problem, we want to
know what element.
So obviously, we're
looking for z.
Now the question is, do we
know everything else?
So yeah, we definitely do.
Let's just go through each
individual thing that we know.
So we know Rydberg constant.
That's just, you know, have that
on your equation sheet.
It's a bunch of constants
agglomerated together.
We know that, for K-alpha
we're told,
this is K-alpha radiation.
Let me draw a cartoon
for you here.
OK?
This is our nucleus, OK?
This is n equals 1, this
is n equals 2.
I'm going to go kind
off the board.
This is 3.
OK?
And K-alpha corresponds to an
electron dropping down from n2
to n1 to here, and then
giving off a photon.
So I'm going to draw a photon as
a squiggly line like this.
OK?
So this is going to be h nu.
This will give you our
K-alpha radiation.
So we know all of
those things.
We know our wave number here.
So we know pretty
much everything.
But what is sigma?
Well, sigma is the correction
factor that Moseley found.
Now, if you're looking at this
and you're thinking, wait,
this looks a lot like the
Rydberg equation, it's because
it's sort of is.
The only difference is that the
Rydberg equation is only
for hydrogenic-type atoms. OK?
So we're talking about hydrogen,
we're talking about
helium plus 1, lithium plus 2.
We can't assume that our target
is hydrogenic, so we
can't use the Rydberg
equation.
So we're using Moseley's
And what Moseley found, just
to show you where the sigma
sort of comes from, and this
is actually reviewed in, I
think, lecture 17 of the
online postings.
What Moseley found was that if
you plot your wave number
versus your z, you've got
points like this.
You've got some sort of line.
OK?
So this is what Moseley found.
And what Moseley basically
did, was he fit
an equation to it.
And the equation looks a lot
like the Rydberg equation.
And because these don't
intersect the origin, we've
got this fitting factor
right here.
We know that for a K-alpha
transition, we're looking at a
sigma equals 1.
OK?
So we're good.
We know our sigma.
We know our n's.
We know n final is
going to be 1.
We know n initial is
going to be 2.
We know the Rydberg constant,
and we know our wave number,
because we're given our
wavelength here.
So we can go ahead and actually
just calculate z.
And let's do that right now.
So let me rewrite this
equation so that
it makes more sense.
Rydberg constant.
1 over.
our n final.
That's 1 squared minus
1 over, our
initial point is 2 squared.
We're looking for our z, and
we're going to subtract off 1,
because we're dealing with
a K-alpha transition.
So you're expected to either
remember that, or have it on
your question sheet.
There's no way to derive that
unless you've got all this
data, which you won't have.
So we've got this squared.
We know everything, so we can
basically reduce this.
This is why on the answer
sheet, you see
something like this.
You kind of skip all
these steps, and we
went right to this.
3/4 z minus 1 squared.
And now you can just
solve for z.
No problem.
OK?
So that's 4 over 3 lambda
Rydberg constant to
the half plus 1.
And that's going to
give you about 23.
You might get 22.9.
You might get 23.1.
We're talking about 23.
That's going to be
the vanadium.
That's the answer to the first
part of this problem.
OK.
We're going to take a second and
clean up, and come right
back and finish the problem.
We're going to start part
B now of problem 2
on the second exam.
So we basically have used the
Moseley equation to find out
an element.
And now we're going to switch
the problem up a little bit
more, and we're going to ask
you to find the smallest
defraction angle for a
particular situation.
So what's the situation?
Let's go back to our
x-ray machine.
The way you actually do x-ray
defraction, you know, it's
acronymized XRD.
The way you do it, is you
have to generate x-rays.
So we accelerate an electron
into some material.
That material gives off a
whole bunch of photons.
You then filter all the photons,
so you only pick up a
certain wavelength.
And we're going to use the
K-alpha wavelength.
And then you get these K-alpha
radiation, which then probes
your sample.
So here we go.
This is what we're looking
at for this part.
We've got K-alpha radiation
coming in, and it's hitting
our structure, which has
a crystal, hopefully.
You're going to do XRD.
And then you're getting off
some defraction, anything
that's reflecting off
of the crystal in
some way, like this.
So the thing you need to know
to do part B, is you need to
know Bragg's Law, Bragg's
equation.
And that's number 3 on the win
list. So I drew this picture
here just to define the
variables, but one thing I
would stress for you at home, is
to please, go home and, you
know, search online, Google
image search even.
Look for a picture like this.
Search Bragg's Law and look
for a picture like this.
And it's actually from this.
It's very easy, just
using geometry, to
derive Bragg's Law.
Bragg's Law is just the
geometric interpretation of
this picture.
OK?
So Bragg's Law, in its
traditional format, is n
lambda equals 2d sine theta.
And I've defined, I drew
the picture to show
the variables here.
We have n, which is--
we'll talk about
n in a second.
We have lambda, which is
our incoming radiation.
We have d, which is the spacing
between planes.
Whatever plane orientation
you're looking at.
2d is the spacing, is there
because you need to come in,
and then come out again.
So you're doing twice the
distance between the planes.
Theta is the angle
at which you're
incident on the material.
And n is going to be your
defraction index.
We're not going to worry about
that in this class.
We're going to assume it's
one, for this class
and for this exam.
So the question is asking us to
find the smallest possible
angle of defraction.
What that means, is that we're
getting all this radiation,
it's hitting our material,
we're moving
our material around.
The question is, what's the
smallest angle at which we're
going to see a peak
on our XRD graph?
I rearranged the equation here,
so theta equals the
inverse sign of lambda
over 2d.
And we're looking for as small
a theta as possible.
This question is really just
mathematical manipulation.
I need to know a couple
important details that
hopefully you've read
about in advance.
So we want to find the smallest
theta possible.
That's the objective
for this problem.
I've drawn the arc sine
function here.
To minimize theta, we want to
have the argument, which I
call x here, we want
the argument to
be as small as possible.
The smaller it is, the closer
to 0 you are for y, which is
theta, in our case.
So we want to minimize the
term in parentheses.
And the way you do that, small
theta means small lambda over
2d, which means you want
to have a large d.
And the reason I'm not using
lambda, the wavelength, as the
knob, is because
lambda is set.
Lambda is predetermined by the
target material you've chosen.
So for our problem,
we have titanium
as our target material.
Which is, we can't change
the lambda K-alpha.
It's set by that material.
So we have lambda K-alpha--
we have k-Alpha coming
off, which is
characteristic of titanium.
So we can't use lambda
as a knob.
The only thing we can mess
around with here, to figure
out this problem, is we
have to look at d.
So we want to have a large d
to minimize this, and to
minimize your theta.
To get a large d, we
need to know the
equation for planar spacing.
OK?
This is your equation
for planar spacing.
And as we sort of talked about
in problem 1, in the prior
video, d planar spacing is the
distance between one plane of
a particular orientation, and
another plane of the same
exact orientation.
OK?
So we're looking at maybe a 011
plane in this unit cell,
and a 011 plane in
this unit cell.
What's the distance
between the two?
That's what this d is.
OK?
So we want to have a large d.
And let's look at what we have
in the equation for d.
We have these hkl.
These are the coefficients the
Miller indices of the plane.
And we have a, which
is the lattice
constant of the material.
We're looking at--
what are we looking at here?
We're looking at tantalum.
We can't change the lattice
constant for constant
temperature and pressure.
So this is nonnegotiable.
We can't change what a is.
The only things that we can
toggle, the only switch we can
toggle now, is h, k, and l.
So the only thing we can do,
is look at different plane
orientations in the crystal.
So this is the logic I used
to go through the problem.
So you want to have as small
an h, k, and l as possible,
because the smaller these are,
the larger d is, et cetera.
So the final piece of
information where we have to
be clever is knowing how to get
the smallest h, k, and l.
We're told that we're
looking at tantalum.
And the students in this class
have access to a periodic
table, which has a vast quantity
of information about
all the elements in it.
One of the things it
has is the crystal
structure of pure elements.
So for tantalum, we're looking
at a bcc structure.
So we're looking at bcc.
bcc, from your reflection rules,
which is the number 5
on the things we need to know
to do this problem--
for bcc, you have to have your
h plus your k plus your l--
let me write it over here--
h plus k plus l--
must be even.
That's a rule, OK?
Proving that is a little bit
beyond the scope of this
class, but that's a rule that
we went over in class, and
it's in the lectures as well.
So we have a couple
things now.
We want to minimize h, k, and
l, and they have to be even.
So basically, what that means
is, we have to go through a
couple permutations.
So let's think about it.
0 0 0.
That's even, but that doesn't
really correspond to a plane.
That doesn't make, you know,
that's not going to help us.
1 0 0, or 0 1 0.
So let me write some
of those down.
Let's look at, you
know, 1 0 0.
Well, that's not even, so
we can't look at that.
So what's the next smallest
thing we could go?
How about 1 1 0?
Those are the smallest
coefficients we can have for a
plane which has the rule
that the h plus k
plus l must be even.
So this could be 1 1 0, this
could be 1 0 1, this
could be 0 1 1.
But what we're basically talking
about, if you remember
from the first problem, is the
family of 1 1 0 planes.
So I plugged in just 1
1 0 for h, k, and l.
You get a d of 3.31 over
the square root of 2.
And then with that d, you know
that you've just maximized the
size of your d, which means
we've minimize the size of
lambda over 2d, and that means
we've minimized our theta.
And now for theta, we can easily
calculate that we're
looking at an angle, if we plug
in for d, which is 3.31
over the square root
of 2, here.
And if we plug in for lambda,
which is given to us as 2.75
angstroms, we get an answer
of 36 degrees.
Put that right in the middle.
And I put in the middle to
emphasize that this is sort of
the logic you have to go
through, sort of a, you know,
circular logic, to get
to that answer.
So that's the answer
to part B.
And remember, this is
pretty much math.
Just manipulation until the very
end, where we discussed
the reflection rules for bcc.
I want to go on to the last part
now, and I'm just going
to erase this.
We only need a little
bit of room.
This last question was actually
my favorite question
in the entire class.
And actually, we only had
3 students get it
right, out of 480.
So this was a great question,
and if you get it right, then
you're doing really
well in the class.
So let's look at C.
It's really a chatty question.
We're not looking
for a number.
The question basically asks us,
we want you to talk about,
to sketch the emission spectrum
of an x-ray target
that's bombarded by photons
instead of electrons.
So let's go back over to what
we said in the beginning.
When we generate x-rays,
generally the way we do it, is
we accelerate an electron
into a target material.
In part B, the target material
was titanium,
but it could be anything.
A very common target
material is copper.
copper K-alpha is a very
standard target material, or
wavelength to use.
You accelerate your electron,
and you generate the spectrum
of electromagnetic radiation.
OK?
So this is our spectrum.
We have large wavelength, we
have small wavelength, we have
some wavelengths
in the middle.
And generally, what we would
see, coming back over here,
I'm going to draw
it like this.
This is what you'd
normally see, if
you're using electrons.
Professor Sadoway refers to
this as the whale-shaped
curve, probably because
we're in New England.
But this is what you
would normally see.
Now, this y-axis is
the intensity.
That's basically the number of
photons you count at some
specific wavelength.
And you see these spikes.
And these spikes correspond
to K-alpha.
This is K-beta.
We'll talk about what they
are in a second.
L-alpha and L-beta.
And et cetera.
You'd have M-alpha, N-beta.
You go all the way down.
But they have very
low intensity.
So this is what we would
normally see if we use
electrons to hit our sample.
But we're not using electrons.
And this is actually the answer
we got for probably 90%
of the solutions
from students.
They just drew the
Bremsstrahlung radiation,
Bremsstrahlung, breaking
radiation.
And they walked away, and
thought they had full credit.
But in reality, this is not the
correct answer, because
you think about what's actually
causing this whale shape.
Once you understand where the
whale shape comes from, then
you understand what happens
if we're using
photons instead of electrons.
So let's actually understand
where these
characteristics come from.
There's two things to pick
up from this plot.
We have a whale shape.
We've also got these spikes.
So first, let's talk
about where the
whale shape comes from.
Let me just do it with blue.
We'll talk about the spikes in
a second, because they're
actually a different
phenomenon.
The whale shape comes from--
let me draw it for you.
Let's zoom in.
Let's zoom in on our
target here.
So here's our target material.
We have an electron
hitting it.
It's just a metal.
And we've got photons
coming up.
Let's zoom in really close
to the surface
of that target material.
Let's go back over here.
So we've got--
looks something like this--
we've got an electron,
which I'll draw in
yellow, coming in.
So here's our electron.
It's about to hit
our material.
Notice I've drawn it with some
crystal structure, because
that's what we're going to talk
about, really zoomed in,
the atomic level.
Now this electron, we've talked
about this in class.
What can happen is that this
electron could come in--
here's its path, normally,
if it wasn't going to get
deflected--
it can come in, and it
can be deflected.
OK?
So it can get deflected off--
let me draw the following
path in blue.
So it can go off like
this, like this.
It could actually go straight
through, without being
deflected at all.
It could actually be reflected
back, like this.
And these different reflections
correspond to the
electron being accelerated.
It's getting accelerated.
If we define our system like
this, so here's our x and our
y, the electron's getting
accelerated in the
y-direction.
This is just a simple location,
but what happens, is
when you accelerate a charge,
you generate radiation.
You generate electromagnetic
radiation.
Accelerating charge.
So, you know, here in the first
path, where it comes
through, and it gets deflected
only by a little bit, you
generate low energy radiation,
low energy photons.
So what we're talking about
here is a very large
wavelength photons coming out.
So we have an electron.
It gets deflected.
It's accelerated.
And from that point, we're
also generating a photon.
Same thing for all these other
paths, but for the larger
angle deflection.
So this one here.
And as you actually start
deflecting back, you're
generating very high energy
electromagnetic radiation.
And this is all because the
electron is basically, you
know, is getting accelerated.
You can actually have, you
know, the maximum energy
photon you can give off here is
a photon that corresponds
to this electron coming
in and getting stopped
completely by the atom.
Think electrostatic repulsion.
So it comes in, and it gets
stopped dead in it's tracks.
So you have some energy, it
was moving some kinetic
energy, and now has
0 kinetic energy.
The energy of your photon that
gets given off is basically
the difference in the two.
And that's what we call here,
on this plot, the short
wavelength limit.
We're going to write SWL.
Because this is lambda, which
means that energy moves in the
other direction.
Lambda goes up, energy
goes down.
Lambda goes down,
energy goes up.
So this is our short wavelength
limit, which means
that is the maximum, the highest
energy we can generate
from this setup here.
So all I'm saying is that you
can get deflections in any
angle across this way, you can
get deflections in angle and
generate any number of
wavelengths of photons with
the minimum wavelength being
this one, that's generated
from this situation.
So I'll just make it very,
very small for you.
So you generate all these
wavelengths, you create all
this energy of photons, and
that's what basically
corresponds to the whale-shaped
curve.
You're more likely to get
deflections that correspond to
something around here, because
you have higher intensity, and
over here, you're less likely
to see those happening.
So that's our whale shape.
And now, let's return
to the problem.
Let's ask, when we use photons,
what's the situation?
Well, photon means we're no
longer looking at an electron.
Our photon is coming in.
And the thing about photons, is
that they're not going to
get deflected like that.
They don't have a charge.
There's no electrostatic
propulsion, for example.
So a photon will either only be
absorbed and re-emitted, or
it will go through
the material.
So what that means is that
there's no process now that
will accelerate a
charge to create
Bremsstrahlung radiation.
And if there's no process to
accelerate a charge, then
there's no way to get
Bremsstrahlung radiation.
So the first thing you need to
do to get most the points on
this problem is to say, look!
There's no Bremsstrahlung
radiation anymore.
There's no charge being
accelerated.
So that's sort of the
first answer.
The second thing to realize is
that these spikes still exist.
Because the reason for these
spikes is a different
mechanism than it is for
the Bremsstrahlung.
These characteristic peaks
correspond to the movement of
an electron to a different
energy level, and then a
dropping back down.
So it's very characteristic
of the material itself.
So a photon can still come in.
It could still liberate
or move an electron.
It could just knock an electron
out of its shell.
Perhaps n equals 1.
And then the n equals 2 electron
will drop down and
fill in the n equals 1 shell
corresponding to K-alpha radiation.
If you had n equals 3 electron
dropping down to n equals 1,
you'd have your K-beta
radiation.
And likewise from, you know, 3
to 2, 4 to 2, L-alpha, L-beta.
So that's the key take-home
message here.
The message is that your
Bremsstrahlung, the thing that
you see in the notes in the
class all the time, the whale
shape with the spikes, that's
two specific mechanisms. The
whale, the Bremsstrahlung,
corresponds to the breaking of
an electron.
These peaks correspond to the
ejection of an electron, and
an electron's moving around
energy levels within the atom.
OK?
So our learning objectives for
this problem, the things that
we've taken home from the
problem overall, is that we
know, for example, Rydberg
equation is only for
hydrogenic-type atoms, and we
know how to use the Moseley's
equation now.
That was part 1.
Part 2, we know Bragg's Law,
and how to use it, and what
all the variables mean.
That's something you should
learn and take home.
And I really highly recommend
that you derive Bragg's Law
from the geometric
interpretation.
And part C, we really wanted
to probe and understand who
conceptually understood
what was happening.
And part C tells us, the thing
that we learned from it is
that this Bremsstrahlung
radiation with the peaks that
we saw in class, that's two
separate mechanisms occurring.
So that's problem number 2,
and I hope you did well.